congratulations on the movie
uh the best compliment i can give you is
that i woke up thinking about it
and that doesn't happen too often so
i'll just say that
um so i have a ton of questions because
i have so much time with you
let's jump in um what movie do you think
you've seen the most
either razor raiders of the lost ark or
jaws
or silence of the lambs it's it's
they're all fighting
they we just watched silence the lambs
again so it's still ticking up
right when you watch movies like that do
you ever
as a director because i've spoken to
some directors and they they've talked
to me or they mentioned that they've
taken notes or they've written down
shots or whatever have you ever watched
any of these films and like
written down something specific that you
want to incorporate into something you
want to do
i don't want to say i always take notes
but i
often take notes watching movies um i
just have a pad next to me
um always try to kind of learn something
but i don't i'm very much lost in this
story but if something
cinematically hits me i'll i'll scribble
it down
on the piece of paper next to me if i'm
if i'm
at a certain point in the making of a
movie
uh especially the writing the latter
stages of writing like this the last
third of the writing process i'm very
careful about what i watch
because that's super super influencing
me i
completely get it do you have a favorite
sci-fi or fantasy film
i mean so many um when you said that i
went to alien
right away just as soon as you said that
sure let's
let's do that one if you weren't writing
and directing
what do you think you would have done
now i would say i would love to have
opened a bookstore and have a small
bookstore but that's more of like a
fantasy retirement job than i guess my
my my my alternate career i guess i i
guess i would have been a doctor right i
mean that's what
my my parents are all my uncles and
aunts are
uh you know i i think that would have
probably you know
been odd bedside demeanor probably
telling stories to the patients
but but uh is there anything that you
collect
fantastic question um
i do collect posters you know so i have
uh but i'm running out of wall space
because i don't like to have them kind
of like hidden anywhere so
sure um i have all of first first
edition hitchcock posters in my house
do you have the huge ones uh no the the
kind of the one sheets
uh so you come in and they're all the
one sheets from the original
including rebecca which is a very rare
first edition to have of
of the of that movie which i love that
movie uh i can only have you posted any
pictures of the posters
you know i should i should actually i
did cross my mind i should
uh do that that wall of those yeah
absolutely because i want to see them so
i'm selfish yeah
um what what tv series have you watched
all the way through more than once
i'm wondering if that actually exists
that that
that i did do that i've been toying with
going back to watch sopranos
from beginning to end um
so that that's probably i'm gonna i've
been toying with that and
hmm i mean you're not counting like
friends in the office right you're not
counting
you got counting that that doesn't work
that's perpetually on in everyone's
house all the time
that doesn't well here's the thing
though like you can that does count
because you can say you know friends is
always on or the office is always on
so that that does count yeah i think you
know the
the the trilogy of of seinfeld office
and and friends i think is more the
friends more is more of my
my daughters and my wife that they have
it on all the time you know
rachel's doing something in our house at
all times so
i i understand what do you wish you knew
earlier in your career that you've
learned as you've made all your projects
wow what a great question um that
the thing that is that at times makes it
dissonant
in its immediate consumption at that
moment that thing
is not necessarily a bad thing and
oftentimes
is the the wonderful thing about it that
makes it
um resonate
uh and and make it makes its brothers
and sisters the other films
even more uh seen in a stronger light so
for example
that um that's that signs was my biggest
opening movie
is because of unbreakable that like that
that
that that kind of relationship of the
dissonant movie to the next movie
you know like that is uh something that
i've learned over time
is you know it's a very strange thing to
do
art and commerce together like that and
um i've been so lucky to have this long
relationship with the audience
and the ones that that that has created
this bond
are the dissonant ones that that that
has that just that
weird thing about them and so i would
tell my younger self because i i tacked
towards that
like my my instinct is that to do that
kind of dissonant thing
and to follow that to just don't don't
worry about
you know being the popular kid on the
day people used to go to see a hitchcock
movie because it was a hitchcock movie
and now people go to see a movie because
of your name has it ever
when did it hit you that like oh my god
my name is actually getting people into
a theater
you know i don't think i've quite
internalized that
entirely yeah i mean it's weird
to uh pass a billboard or something we
went to a wedding
the first thing we did is after the
pandemic the first kind of thing we went
to a friend's wedding and
i it was it was in baltimore and
drove up and got out of the car come
into the hotel
and all the bell boys had the masks on
and they were like old
old and they were all yelling yelling it
out and i'm like wow
this is wild that they're that they're
coming they're interested in the author
and then went into the starbucks and the
guy at the starbucks was like july 23rd
man july 23rd i was like
wow this is you know it's it's amazing
uh i take it very seriously the
relationship
um uh of of the craft of it that that
relationship
it's one that you know we have with
authors of
of novels it's one we have with authors
of plays
um and it's rare more more rare in our
in our the movie industry
um just a blessing dude i you know what
can i what can i say i mean you know
we're
my movies opening up in movie theaters
in a few weeks here and
you know first one that went all over
the world in 1999 so it's like man
it's amazing what you don't know about
the story you just told me is that
uh the the employees at the hotel and at
the starbucks were all given five
dollars each by your wife to say these
guys
all right is that right yes i just want
to keep
it by the way if we work the other way
my wife would be like here's five
dollars not to say
not just so just don't don't tell him
that don't say it don't remind him he
has it because
here's five dollars just don't say
anything but uh you've worked with all
different
budgets and i'm curious if you find
working with a lower budget
is almost more cr like more i don't know
um
it's easier not because it's less money
but because it's almost less
responsibility the people paying for the
movie and
if it doesn't work it's not the end of
the world like can you sort of talk
about what it's like working in these
different budget levels
yeah i mean for me it's been the secret
sauce
uh um to do these four movies
and make them you know at a very low
number the lowest i can make it for
um i i in that relationship with my
partners
i can deliver the most unique and
provocative
uh product which i think is our weapon
that to be different the more the the
more different it is the better it is
for us in the marketplace that's my
thesis
and but i'm being responsible you know
um it's a very interesting thing you
know we're trying to do something
anomalous like say we're releasing old
in the summer and
honestly every movie that's out it's at
least you know
10 times the cost of the movie of old
right and
um and i i it does give me comfort when
i
it allows me to do very provocative
things darker things i don't have to
you know feel like i have to play it
safe i can be very dissonant like we
were saying you know
um and know that for the most part we're
we're gonna be okay you know and um
we're building a a relationship that the
studio and i
love with with the with the audience i
think it's been it's a very special
thing dude that's going on i
um i don't mind you know doing it this
way
in fact i love it you know and in fact
other filmmakers i would say
you should make your movies for the
lowest number that you can have freedom
that that that should be your goal
there's an equation for that and the
moment you take the extra dollar
you have now committed to something
other than i'm going to listen to
the the these strange voices that are
telling me slow it down or kill this
person or have this you know
you know this question i asked to a lot
of filmmakers
but i think you're in a different
position because i think a lot of people
want to be in business with you
and if you came up with an idea but
there must have been something
or maybe uh if you could get the
financing for any dream project
uh what would you make and why and i'm
not sure if this question applies to you
but let's let's see
yeah um i don't know if it applies to me
dude because that's exactly what i'm
doing
um i'm trying to think is there a movie
to finance that yeah like i said this
might be a
question that doesn't apply to you
because as i said i would imagine
everyone wants to be in the night
business so it's like well you know
well you well you bring up an
interesting thing like say there was a
big franchise movie right that i was
like wow i'm really interested in this
because it has a great opportunity
but i want to do the small version of
that
and that has happened i won't say what
movies that has happened that has
crossed my mind wow i would be
interested to do the 18 million dollar
version
of that if if everyone was willing to do
that
um uh and i it crosses my mind but then
it becomes you know
it's so that particular ip is so
important
to uh that the that studio or that that
that company that risking it in that way
makes no sense
you know why would you allow try to
invent it in that way
um there's actually been i think three
of those situations where i was like hey
i'll do the really kind of like down and
dirty version of that
so it's kind of the reverse a little bit
it's almost like i know will they allow
me not to take the money and not to
spend the money
it's do it in this in this way but then
the ramifications of that are
uh limitations that i believe in that
are that are that are
positive i'm let me ponder more maybe i
can think about it but yeah it's weird
because that is what i'm doing right i'm
i'm financing these movies that are not
that wouldn't be able to be financed in
the studio system traditionally
uh do you have a lot of scripts in the
desk that have never been made
no i wrote one in college that i almost
made
um at the time and and and then i made
uh
uh the other movie for miramax at that
time but there's only one since then
that i've written
that um are you talking labor of love
yeah labor labor labor's there there's
actually two
there's one more that i i have another
idea for
that i i may make one name so that one's
the so there's two
there's two whatever happened with labor
of love i think you were going to do
that with bruce willis
yeah whatever what happened with that
one you know it's been kind
it's it's emerged so many times in my
career
a couple times with denzel um and
it's it's just a drama you know it's
just there's nothing
it's not a thriller it's just a drama
it's something that
i wrote it was it's a romance
essentially you know
and um i wrote it was the first thing
that i wrote that actually brought me
into the industry in a real way it was
so long ago
um so it means a lot to me it's very
emotional
um at this point it's almost a period
piece because it was set
in like you know 1993 94
you know so it's 94 it's like you'd have
it won't make any sense now with cell
phones and
everything that we have smartphones and
so you would either literally have to do
it as a period piece
now uh from that time period uh it's
very meaningful to me
almost it almost feels like a novel or
something that i wrote but that's
um trying to know when and
when to do it and how to do it has
always been a a been on my mind
it is a very meaningful piece to me what
do you which of your films
went through the biggest change from
your first draft
on the page to what people see on screen
or saw on screen
great question man let's see my initial
reaction is
is sixth sense because that was the one
that started out as just a straight
crime kind of you know there was no
therapist
it was a serial killer movie when it
first when i first wrote it
um it was a you know it was it was a
crime scene photographer
was the was the main character and his
child sees the
the victims of the of the serial killer
so
that was the original idea that i had in
my head
which of your films do you think had the
longest had the most deleted
scenes wow great question
that's that one i'm be guessing i would
be guessing at because
that's a tricky one you'd have to see i
have all these cards for each scene when
you're editing and then as they go into
the graveyard
as they come out they go into this this
pile that i call the graveyard that that
that
that that list goes i'm thinking it's
split
i'm thinking it's split that had the
that had whole story lines that came out
character that came out you know the
first cut of that was like three hours
so was it was big right and that's
and i apologize for not knowing but do
all of your deleted scenes
end up on like a blu-ray or a dvd or
there's still a lot of things
sort of in a basement somewhere uh not
all of them
end up i i i'm careful not to make the
analysis on the blu-ray
so forensic that you it's hard to watch
the movie you know
um so there's a little calibration that
goes on in terms of
let's say for example there was a
character that was cut out i'm
that may or may not be okay for you to
watch the movie
after you knew that so i tried to you
know i want to make
you know keep the purity of the movie as
much as possible i don't mind
scenes that give you more depth into the
characters so i
tend to put those kind of scenes in the
deleted scenes
not every scene that was deleted
completely um
i believe many years ago you met with
spielberg about writing a fourth indiana
jones movie
yeah did you ever come up with your
mcguffin and the idea or was it more
just like a basic meeting
oh my god it was it was i mean it was
fantastic you know obviously raiders is
like you know my favorite movie of all
time and so this was a dream
um like you know to be asked as a kid to
go see
a movie in a movie theater then later to
be asked by that person to write one of
those in the future i mean
that's his you know i mean i like you
could pin you know faint i could faint
at that moment it was amazing
um i do have my notebooks i still have
those with all my ideas for
for that movie i did have i did have a
take i did have a take
um i talked to everybody involved and it
was so nascent at that time that movie
so every no one had gotten
we hadn't everyone hadn't gotten into a
room yet they were kind of bouncing
ideas off of me
so everyone had different ideas of of
what to do but i ha i definitely
when you say that i have in my head and
like it's a green notebook and i i
i had this idea it was it was it was a
darker idea
god did you because every every you know
uh indiana jones movie has the mcguffin
so but had you thought about what that
was yet
i i i did i did yeah i i hadn't i
looked i hadn't i hadn't pitched it to
them or anything like that but i had an
idea
okay i won't press you any further um i
know that you also expressed interest
many years ago in harry potter do you
view that as something that sort of got
away
or are we sort of like these movies are
really good it's cool
oh definitely you know we we our kids
watch them and we all watch them and
and love them they have a kind of a um
almost a nostalgia about them now
um a taunt an innocence about them that
you know represented a certain time in
filmmaking i think
and um i find them you know beautiful i
know
obviously i know a lot of my you know
rupert's now in my show and
you know um so i've always felt close to
them when i met them all as kids and
you know i was in my late 20s when i was
meeting them and now
they're older than i am when i met them
and so it's weird you know
um it's amazing it would have been a you
know those are those are more than a job
that you have to change your life you
know those are you got to move
to england and you upload you know
change your whole life and
um i guess it goes right to the core of
are you making original movies or are
you not kind of so it was there was some
really fundamental when you're making
movies of that scale and all of that
stuff
and again kind of talking about all the
this those were early days but talking
about
what type of voice are you and what is
the best way to tell
those stories where your voice can be
your voice is it in large scale movies
like that
um does your imagination work that way
or does it work in this kind of
almost you know indie way
sure roger deakins and steven soderbergh
are famous for
very limited coverage on set they
generally have one camera set up they're
getting very limited
you know almost no coverage uh roger
famously shot i believe
blade runner and and james bond with one
camera
um and so i'm curious when you're on set
how much coverage are you trying to do
how much are you just doing the minimal
coverage
yeah there's no there's no coverage per
se
um we shoot everything that i've drew um
there's no
99.99999 percent of the time there isn't
anything else that we're doing it's just
the things i drew
and that's what we're we're shooting
exactly in that way
um um when roger and i uh
did the village together you know we
kind of worked out
the shots and that's it that's what
that's what's there um
uh and so it's it's play-like and you
know i'm i'm of that mind
uh entirely of the old school mentality
of make the movie in your head and go
and go get that movie
sure how do you typically like to talk
to your actors before they step on set
the first day
are you giving them uh certain things to
watch certain things to read
like how what is that dynamic like
it varies accurate actor project project
but
there is a uh we do rehearse a lot it's
like uh it's like a theater
and i it's like on old i you know it was
a very much like a theater group and i
would say to them hey you know
think of the the the blocking and the
movement of the with
your relationship to the camera as dance
moves
and not as hey my character would do
this so my character would do that
it's it this is the choreography of the
movement of the camera
and how i was thinking of it in terms of
your positioning in juxtaposition to
others and in relationship to the camera
and when you take a step forward we're
moving this way the other i see the
other person her cheek comes in
all that stuff and think of it as
choreography
and then i'm gonna talk you through the
emotional meaning of that choreography
and within that seeming structure
there's infinite ways to perform it um
and so when it's very complicated
choreography we
i i'm very i try to do it early so that
they get comfortable with hey this is
how i'm seeing it
and ones that are more fluid like hey i
have a locked off frame and you can move
whatever you want into the bathroom out
of the bathroom come in you know there's
like a scene where they're
in the movie where they're fighting and
i put a a light
on a bed and one in the bathroom and i
was like go wherever you want
and these are the these are the hit
points but
you could be as like i said you could be
entirely in the bathroom and i never see
you if you wanted to do that version
that take
so there's times where i'm like you know
your
your complete spontaneity is what i'm
looking for
uh jumping into old because i'm
realizing i'm just about out of time
um this is your first time shooting
something out of philadelphia uh will it
be your last time
filming something out of philadelphia
um i don't think so i you know the next
few movies that i have in my head are
are kind of you could shoot them all in
philly um
um one of them takes place in in in
a couple locations outside but they're
very contained so i
you know a lot of them could be done the
traditional way but i'm
getting more comfortable with writing
exterior and then it's not philadelphia
normally it's exterior philadelphia or
interior building philadelphia um and
probably because my kids have gotten
older and
um i feel the freedom to do that one of
the things that's interesting about this
is that you have different actors
playing the same characters um what
some of them i should say was there ever
like a sort of in your mind
like do i want to make it that every 15
minutes
there's gonna be a different actor like
sort of talk about in your mind
the progression how you wanted to depict
that on screen
and how much is it sort of like when you
have like a movie star or a star that
you need to like have in the movie
you sort of have to play a little bit
more like i need this character on
screen for an hour
because they're like a star and they're
helping me sell the movie versus
does that make any sense yeah yeah i
didn't quite think of it but yes
yes i didn't quite think of it like that
but there was a math equation here of
making sure i wasn't looking at
prosthetics the whole movie that was
critical to me i didn't want that i
didn't want that feeling
i wanted it to be um various ways of
representing
this movement of look and age and i
i remember and even now the idea of
insinuating people on the edge of frame
or being behind them
and you know uh i thought that was a
wonderful way to
be provocative with the audience to kind
of say well now the kids are older
um but i'm not showing them to you and
what i wonder what they look like and
you're just getting
wow they look their hair looks the same
but they don't they don't quite look the
same
that movement of can i find
actors that really look like each other
that are
you know 15 years apart can i can i do
that they move and they
they actually can feel like each other
how can we use cgi or prosthetics in a
very gentle delicate way that create
like wow i'm seeing
i'm seeing them there's in that from
that scene in that scene they're
slightly older you're catching it or you
might not catch it that kind of thing
so we analyzed that and every actor got
how old they were in every scene they
got a chart of like
age age for every every scene that they
were in
i don't want to be specific because
obviously i don't want to spoil anything
but
this is one of those movies that could
have ended in a few different places in
my mind
and i don't want to uh i think the
ending's great but i'm curious how you
ended up where you did
because you and again it's hard without
being specific but there is
there's a few places where i'm like
where you know what i mean i guess
what was was it always this ending or
did you ever have another version of it
or
like a different thought of where this
could end it was always this ending for
me
the graphic novel which had no ending
essentially
um and didn't explain anything had a few
frames
in it where i thought they were
insinuating something
and so i kept writing that version of
the story in my head i go oh
that that must mean that if that that
image of that person over there
hmm that that must mean that that
there's something else going on and so
for me it was very much from the graphic
novel like you know
almost like a painting that was
unfinished that they insinuating what
the rest of the painting was so
that ending that you have was from that
it was from from that so it was always
that version
and there were different rhythms of of
how did to convey that that ending that
there was various versions of conveying
that but it was always that end
thank you so much for your time
hopefully these questions were not too
painful
no super fun dude as always